what I want to do in this video is think
about how the opportunity cost can
change as we move from scenario to
scenario this is going to be
particularly this example but it's a
phenomenon that you will see in many
economic scenarios so let's say we're
starting off in Scenario F we are
vegetarians we are only getting berries
we are not spending any time going after
rabbits but now we're starting to I
guess crave protein and we say well what
is going to be the opportunity cost if I
go for that extra rabbit if I go for
that extra rabbit then what's going to
happen well I'm going to have to stay on
my production possibilities frontier and
so I'm going to move to scenario E so if
I go after that one extra rabbit I am
going to give up I'm going to give up 20
berries so my opportunity cost in
Scenario F sitting in Scenario F of
going after that one rabbit is 20
berries now let's keep going what
happens if I'm in scenario e I'm already
on average eating one rabbit or finding
one rabbit a day and I want to go to two
rabbits a day what am I going to give up
let me do that in that same color what
will I give up
well now I am going to give up 40
berries 40 berries this is interesting
now let's say we're in scenario D and we
want and we want even more rabbits we're
really starting to become carnivores now
what am I going to give up well I'm
going to give up 60 berries if I find if
I'm able to get three rabbits every day
on average then I'm only going to get
180 berries now instead of 240 and let's
just keep going so if I want yet another
rabbit every day then I'm going to have
to give up then I'm gonna have to give
up 80 berries 80 berries and then
finally just to feel some sense of
completion if I become a complete
carnivore and if I want to get on
average five rabbits a day I'm gonna
have to give up another 100 berries and
go to not having any berries at all and
so you might see something interesting
the more squirrels
sorry not squirrels although the biggest
are similar the more rabbits that I'm
going
after the every time I I try to go after
another incremental rabbit I'm giving up
more and more berries my opportunity
cost is increasing and so this
phenomenon that's it's not always the
case but it's the case in this example
increasing opportunity cost opportunity
increasing opportunity cost every as we
increase the number of rabbits we're
going after and you can do it the other
way you could say okay what if as we
increase as especially if you did it on
a unit basis if you said every
incremental barrier every incremental
hundred Berry's we're going after but
the numbers aren't is easy right over
here you'll actually see something going
the other way
but the question an interesting question
is okay Sal you set up the numbers like
this earlier two videos ago but but why
would this make sense why is this idea
of increasing opportunity costs showing
up in a lot of different economic and
you could call this an economic model we
have we've simplified our economic
reality the choices that we have to make
down to two variables the number of
rabbits we have to go after or the
number of berries but why does this show
up in economic models and just be clear
it does not show up in all of them but
to think about our example is a
hunter-gatherer we started here in
Scenario F in Scenario F we aren't we
we've decided to not pursue any rabbits
even even the slower not so quick-witted
rabbit who maybe you know likes to hang
out with you next to you and it likes to
play with your Spears or your bow and
arrow you are not even going after that
rabbit instead you are choosing to spend
all of your time on on the berries and
not only are you getting the low
literally the low-hanging fruit the easy
berries you're getting the barrier the
berries that are further up the bush the
berries that you have to get cut by
thorns to get the berries that you have
to climb trees to get so you're getting
even hard to get berries and you're not
going after even easy to get rabbits but
now all of a sudden if you say well you
know that rabbit who's been hanging out
with me he's been kind of asking for it
and so that was very easy to get it
didn't take much time on a given day to
get those really easy rabbits who like
to hang out with you you're not giving
up a lot in terms of berries you're not
giving up a lot in terms of berries one
it didn't take you much time to get
those literally those those slow and
maybe less quick-witted rabbits and
you're giving up in that same amount of
time the very hard to get berries so
you're only going to give up about
twenty of them now if you want two
rabbits to two rabbits a day not only
you're going to get the the slowest of
the rabbits the ones that aren't afraid
of humans now you're gonna have to go
get the slightly faster rabbit the the
the slightly faster rabbit who wants to
die a little bit less and is maybe a
little bit sharper and you're now not
giving up the berries that are way up in
the tree and that are protected by
thorns you're giving up berries that are
closer down the tree so this is going to
take you a little bit more time to do
then this right over here and in that
little bit more time you're also giving
up berries that were easier to get and
so this phenomenon is going to happen
all the way until you know in this
scenario we're trying to get five
rabbits a day you are literally going
after the quickest and the smartest
rabbits but you insist on going them and
in your pursuit of these quick faster
rabbits you're even ignoring berries
you're literally like stepping on
berries you're not eating the berries
that are right next to you because
you're so obsessed with with eating
rabbits so hopefully that gives you a
sense of why increasing opportunity cost
does show up and it when you graphically
show it in terms of a production
possibilities frontier it shows up in
this bow shaped curve and you can see it
because as we go from this point to this
point you see that the the as we
increase one the slope the negative
slope is increasing so or another way to
think about in Scenario F the slope is
roughly like this and I encourage you to
review the algebra playlist if the idea
of slope is is confusing to you but at F
the slope is like that I'm drawing the
slope of the tangent line right over
here at E it gets even steeper you're
giving up even more
you're giving up even more of the
berries per unit rabbit and now indeed
you're giving up even more and then
you're giving up even more and so this
this whenever you see a bow shaped curve
like this so a curve that literally
looks like this this shows that you have
increasing opportunity costs as you
increase more and more units you're
going to have to give up more and more
of the alternative